all right blaze missed all right
bladesmiths blaze miss bladesmiths
bladesmiths welcome the keel test
it's time to get medieval
our very own dealer of death
the doer of deadly deeds
the kill test master
doug marcaida
yeah he just looks like a murderer i am
really nervous
all right alex
the balance is light allowing it to be a
very fast weapon you can use middle hand
long-handed or for close quarters your
weapon will kill
all right trevor trick-or-treat treat
indeed it will be a treat
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right trevor the tip alone
penetrates deeply into the gut and the
edges here are sharp enough to well make
it lose his head
overall sir it will kill thank you sir
bladesmiths a hanzo's katanas first duty
is to kill
all right mike and europe first are you
ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
yes
mike your edge is razor sharp
but more importantly there's bone on
your edge
but your edge didn't roll did not chip
and your blade stayed true
overall sir
your blade
will kill
thank you justin you ready yes sir let's
do this
ah
so
right tristan the balance of your blade
is very good it's light it's fast it's
easily maneuverable
but
when steel meets the skull there were
some problems your blade because you're
using bend
also on the edge right here you took
some chipping
but overall
looking at the dummy
i think your weapon will definitely kill
thank you
bladesmiths this is the kill test the
grim reaper uses the scythe to harvest
the souls of humans when it's their time
to test the lethality of your scythe i
will take your scythe
and try to rip out the soul of these
ballistics dummies
chase you up first you ready ready as
i'll ever be let's do this
[Music]
oh
damn
all right chase let's talk about your
scythe right here the edge
is sharp your tip punctures deep
breaking ribs and right into the heart
pulling out its soul
this weapon sir
it will kill good job thank you
all right brandon your turn you ready
yes sir let's do this let's do it
i'm pretty nervous but i'm excited at
the same time because i think the
ballistics dummy test is one of the
coolest tests i've ever seen
oh
that is awesome
all right bran let's talk about your
scythe right here
aside from reaping the soul out of this
ballistics dummy i seem to have taken
the clavicle and sternum with it
your point here really digs in but in
doing so and hitting the bone you have a
little chip right here at the tip
oh no and one
on the blade right there
but most importantly
there it is thank you sir all right
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
now in greek mythology perseus uses
sword to decapitate medus and remove her
head from her body to use it as a weapon
to that end i will take your weapon and
help me to deliver some killing slashes
and blows to liberate her head from her
body
robert you are first you ready for this
yes sir
[Music]
all right robert let's talk about your
sword here i like the design that you
have the damascus
in there
but it's so heavy
it's about five pounds over here but the
thing is it's so forward heavy most of
the weights up here when i'm lifting
this i can feel all the stress right
there this is supposed to be meant to be
a single-handed use weapon
now your edge
is plenty sharp it was easy to thrust
and cut and
it will kill
all right jared your turn you ready sir
yes sir
[Music]
all right jared
first up
you nailed the balance on this as a
one-handed sword it's about three pounds
lighter than your opponents your edge
is razor sharp every slash is deep the
thrust no issues at all and most
importantly sir
it will kill
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test mickey you're up first you ready
for this you know what let's do this
i've designed my blade to do one thing
slice cut and kill
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right we can talk about your katana
right here to be able to wield a sword
this size the handle is what drives the
blade it's hard to get very accurate
because it's big but what i love about
your blade
is how sharp your edge is
it cut into the skull pieces of it came
off and what's important about this
katana is
it will kill thank you sir good job all
right colin it's your turn you ready for
this
let's do this
first up the ginormous handle
it's very hard to grab a complete grip
on this
but you have a very sharp tip that
punctures easily into this ballistics
dummy but it doesn't lacerate on the way
out
it did crush the skull and any kind of
damage like this done to anybody
it will kill thank you
bladesmiths this is the kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your sword
will do i will take your weapon and
deliver killing blows on this ram
carcass
bill ready for the kill
yes i am
the ram thing is really appropriate for
the period of the weapon that we
reproduced but it's got hair on it that
hair is pretty abrasive and that's the
only thing i'm worried about my sword
cutting that hair to get to the flesh
[Music]
man
that's one sharp silver right bill let's
talk about your blade right here first
up your handle feels good it's got a
nice shape to it that just fits nicely i
like the guard i like the bronze that
you have right there i can immediately
tell where the edge is
this is what i don't like about your
bleed
it doesn't allow me to have fun two hits
it's done
this is really light fast and sharp bill
it will kill
thank you
all right blade spits welcome to the
kill test your dark street gun shys look
intimidating but are they deadly to find
that out i will take your weapon deliver
some killing blows in this ballistic
stomach
james you're up first you ready for this
there's nothing i can do to stop it all
right let's do it
to say i'm nervous right now is an
understatement at this point it's out of
my hands i just hope it can hold up
[Music]
all right james
first up that's a beast
it's very forward heavy so it definitely
feels like a chopper all the way through
now your handle here by adding this fur
around it i can't get a good grip on it
because it's so soft
now your edge
is sharp
overall sir
it will kill thank you all right paul
your turns are you ready i'm ready let's
do this
i built my blade to be very light it
definitely makes me nervous seeing the
ballistics dummy because i know there's
a lot of hard bones in there and i'm
definitely a little bit worried that
could bend even break in half you never
know what's going to happen
[Music]
all right paul first up i really
appreciate the damascus pattern that you
brought out here
now
the fact that i can hold the weapon out
extended like this shows just how light
this weapon is for its size and because
of that i can cut deeply into this
without using the weight just velocity
alone but after that striking skull just
picked up a little bit of a bend overall
sir it'll kill thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
now we'll take your weapon and deliver
some thrust and slashes on our
dummy from the north
trevor you're up first you ready for
this i'm ready
[Music]
all right trevor first up it is so light
just like a needle
your point here allows for a very deep
penetration without any effort overall
sir it will kill
good job all right victor your turn so
you ready
so
[Music]
all right victor talk about your sword
here it's not very light
overall though it's pointy enough to
thrust
the edge with a weight cut
and
it will kill
thank you all right bladesmiths welcome
to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will take your
sword and deliver some killing blows to
this ballistics dummy peter are you up
first you ready yes sir let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right peter first up your edge is
sharp the balance feels good but
it did take quite a pronounced bend but
the more important thing is
it'll keel
i typed that perfectly
all right doc everett are you ready sir
let's do some surgery
[Music]
[Music]
yikes
all right everett your edge is very
sharp it slashes nicely your tip
punctures easily cuts on the way out
with all these cuts
it'll kill
[Music]
all right blade fists well frankly your
frankish throwing axes look fantastic
but are they lethal well to find that
out i will take your weapons and deliver
some well
hellish of a blow on this ballistics
dummy
justin you up first you ready split it
to the teeth
[Music]
[Music]
all right justin every chop and slash is
deep overall sir it'll kill
thank you
all right nick it's your turn ready have
fun let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
all right nick upon impact
crushes the face easily in the head
your edges they dig in with every chop
and slash
it'll kill thanks doug good job
all right bladesmiths to test the
lethality of your bore swords i will
deliver thrust and cuts on this boar
carcass
john you're first you ready for this
absolutely
[Music]
all right john first up i like the
balance i like that i can put two hands
in it it's all void enough to where i
can hold on and i can tell where the
edge is and when we're pushing and
thrusting as it's meant to be
the tip is sharp enough to thrust all
the way through your edges as you can
see
are sharp enough to cut pieces out of
this poor carcass overall sir
it'll kill
thanks sir congrats
thanks man
all right isaac your turn are you ready
for this let's make some bacon
[Music]
[Music]
all right
first up it's much lighter
so it's easier to control when you're
moving with the blade
and as you can see when i was thrusting
in there the point you have here the
edges are very sharp it thrusts all the
way in and even when it hits bone
it's got a very good flex to it do not
pick up again
overall sir
your boar sword
will make bacon and kill
thank you bladesmiths the tabar shishbar
is one weapon with multiple
personalities
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will take you to
barcheshbart and use both ends to
deliver killing blows on this ballistic
stummy
mark you up first you ready
let's see it
[Music]
[Music]
omar
it is sharp
that chopped right
into the chest cavity breaking the bone
this axe dug in and gutted him
your mace definitely will crush you can
see the breaking bones inside
your weapon will kill
thank you
chris you ready i am
oh my gosh
into the lung into the heart
your mace definitely penetrated through
the skull
bones
are broken i don't think it's gonna end
well
your weapon is heavy
and i'm not a fan of heavy weapons
only because you have to carry it to
battle but
overall
it will kill
thank you
the saw back hunting sword as the name
implies it's used for hunting to hunt
for the kill
i'm gonna take your weapon deliver
lethal blows on this ram carcass
trevor you're up first you ready for
this
yes sir let's do this
my heart is just pounding
and all i can think is don't break don't
break
yes
all right trevor first up
the balance of this weapon is beautiful
it feels like it can move with it it
thrusts
it's sharp and the first cut alone
it lacerated the carcass over here the
second one the third one's pretty much
just to finish it off when i grab onto
your handle it feels comfortable i can
tell where the edge is
now there's one area right here where
there's a little bit where the edge
rolled because it would hit thick spine
but overall
your weapon sir
will kill
thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do according to its
historic design i will try to cut this
big carcass in half
wayne europe first you ready for this
absolutely
oh man one and done
well now
all right wayne
your foul sean is beautiful it is sharp
it cut through the spine and all the way
through the pig
it's a little bit heavier for a
one-handed weapon but it is well
balanced
overall sir it will kill
awesome
all right mark your turn sir are you
ready let's give it a shot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right mark talk about your foul
shone here it's a nice lighter blade
your edges are sharp enough to cut
through spine but the problem i have
here is your guard
your edges here are not rounded they dig
in right here where the thumb is
but your blade sir it will kill
thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test
to test the lethality of your weapon i
will deliver killing blows on this
ballistics dummy
fill you up first you ready for this yes
sir man let's do it
going into this test my heart's starting
to pump a little faster doug's hopefully
just going to destroy this ballistics
dummy and we're going to have pieces
flying all over the place and blood on
the walls
[Music]
[Music]
all right phil the design you have here
is
scary
that's a very thick spine you have it
the edges are sharp as you can see
very deadly
one thing about this is that
it's heavy
that is something to take into account
when you're carrying something like this
into battle and you gotta move multiple
times but more importantly your weapon
will kill
thank you sir
all right john your turn are you ready
let's do it
i'm feeling good about the kill test i
know my blade is sharp and i think it'll
cut really well
[Music]
[Laughter]
pushed out a rib
all right john i love the feel of the
blade you can really fight with it
because it's lighter your blade also is
very slim that it penetrates in there
and there's no resistance even enough to
push out a rib
more important i love the balance i love
the feel
and it will kill
thanks
sir right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
the european will do i'll take your
weapon deliver some slashes of thrust on
this big carcass scott you're up first
you ready for this oh yeah let's do this
i am super excited to see doug chop up a
pig with my blade i run my mouth all the
time like i can do that i can do that so
now is the time to see if i can really
walk the walk because i know i can talk
the talk
[Music]
oh
all right scott first up it is light the
balance really allows for velocity and
recovery with this blade and most
importantly
it will
yeah
all right mark your turns are you ready
heck yeah let's do this
i'm ready to see my sword destroy cut
slice but i want to see the insides of
that pig
[Music]
you're just hanging there like chewing
gum
all right mark talk about your blade
here it's beautiful in this creation the
edge is sharp i was quite amazed with
the cuts i was surprised that it cut
that deeply the one thing though is that
that guard right there there rubs on my
knuckle not bad but it does rub on the
knuckle despite that he will kill yes
alright ladies welcome to the keel test
it's time to get medieval on your broad
sword we'll take your weapons to deliver
some slashes and blows on this
ballistics dummy
club me up first you ready for this yeah
let's have
fun i'm feeling confident about my sword
but i really don't know what could go
wrong i i've never
made a sword before
[Music]
all right colton first up i really
appreciate the balance you have with
this because it's easy to wield with
forward slashes back hands and thrusting
with it your edge is sharp
now your handle it's just a little bit
too tall for me in a tense of it's a
wider here but i can still get a good
grip on it and more importantly this
sword with its balance
it will kill thank you
all right scott to your turns are you
ready yes sir let's do this
i'm ecstatic to see doug playing with my
sword
because it's exciting to see what it can
do to the human body what it's built for
[Music]
it's got first stop
that is beautiful to look at
now the wire wrap does give me some kind
of contours to hold on to every
slice or should i say chop dug deep into
this ballistics dummy
overall
the kind of weapon and damage you can do
with this
it will kill
thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the kill
test now to find out how lethal your
weapons are i will take your lack of
bars and deliver killing blows on this
big carcass
joshua you're up first you ready for
this yeah let's do it
i don't mind going first other than the
fact that i might pass out because of
anticipation but i'm ready to see this
thing get to
work okay
all right joshua first up your blade
it's a pork chopper
on its thrust you see the wound channel
it creates such a big deep gash
it's fun to wield it's sharp and most
importantly
it will kill good job thank you
all right jesse your turn you ready
absolutely let's do it
i'm really anxious about this test it's
a little bit heavy hoping that that's
not gonna be a determining factor i
don't know how this is gonna go
[Music]
first up your blade has to wait that
every chop into something want to keep
going it wants to keep going and going
and going to where
pretty much took me with it
good chops good cuts and more
importantly
it will kill
thank you
all right bladesmiths to find out how
lethal your nagamakis are i will take
your weapons deliver killing blows
slashes and thrusts on this wild boar
carcass
braxtonia of course you ready for this
i'm ready go ahead let's do this
man we have hogs around where i'm from
skin is very very thick i'm nervous but
there's nothing i can do
i just gotta let the chips fall where
they lay
all right braxton
your nagamaki here is definitely not
boring
it is razor sharp every cut with this
thick wild boar carcass allowed me to
peel off layers of the very thick high
that it has
also
the lightness that you have with this
blade allows for switching with the grip
here it's got very good grip in the
handle i can index exactly where the
edges at all times overall sir your
nagamaki
will kill
thank you
all right jake it's your turn ready for
this chop them up let's do this
it makes me a little bit nervous i
really want mine to chop through the
bore as well but the blade can actually
take a lot of damage during the boar
testing because there's bones
i know that braxton's blade is at a very
high bar mine needs to perform just as
good as his
all right jake let's talk about your
nagamaki here it's sharp
wielding this weapon is a lot of fun
also the weight you have here and the
balance works overall sir your nagamaki
will kill thank you all right blazbis
this is the pig carcass slice and dice
i will take your weapon to deliver
killing blows on this big carcass
john your first you ready for this let's
make some bacon bud
this is not an easy test to pass this is
where i find out did i make a sword or a
couple pieces of scrap metal
oh yeah
[Music]
yes all right john your messer is sharp
it's a little bit forward heavy but the
weight
lends itself to chop the pig in half now
you're by knife razor sharp those cuts
alone were cutting deeply with every
move and overall sir it will kill oh yes
all right jeff your turn you ready yes
sir let's do this doug marcotte is gonna
pick up the stuff that i made
and he's gonna test it on this pig so
i'm a little bit nervous at this point
all right jeff
your master
beautiful balance it's not forward heavy
it actually is something i can wield
forward same balance on the recovery
when i'm pulling back to cut now your by
knife the edge is razor sharp with every
cut and stab that it does overall stir
your weapons they will kill thanks sir
all right bladesmiths to find out what
kind of lethal damage your weapon will
do i will take your greek copis and
deliver some killing blows in this
ballistics dummy
john york first you ready ready i'm
pretty nervous there's no way to prepare
yourself for this moment i'm just gonna
hope that my blade survives
[Music]
all right john let's talk about your
copis here there is a little crack that
goes around the edge on both sides
when i saw the tip i thought that gonna
be tip heavy it's not there's good
recovery with this it's a very powerful
weapon sir
it will kill
thank you
all right mike it's time to have fun
with your blade are you ready i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good job
thanks
all right mike let's talk about your
greek copis right here it is heavier but
every shot that i go in there cuts you
have a sharp edge but more importantly
sir
it will kill thank you good job
all right blade smith this is the kill
test to find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do i will take
your christmas and deliver slashes and
thrust on this big carcass john you're
up first you ready for this oh yeah
let's do this
i'm just so nervous at this point that
my legs are actually shaking and i don't
know if i'm just so nervous to see it in
the hands of somebody else or nervous
it's gonna break
[Music]
[Music]
good job
i think having these waves here
pretty much answers what kind of damage
that will do every thrust pierces in i
could feel it riding the skin and
cutting if you look at the wound channel
on the way out it's that wide this
definitely has a sharp edge
overall sir
it will kill
thank you all right steve it's your turn
you ready
yep let's do this
[Music]
dude that's impressive
all right steve's talk about your chris
here
the balance of this blade is really good
it's done in such a way to where i can
really get speed in cutting and because
your angles of the edge over here is
almost like an acute edge it allows to
cut deeply into this big carcass it's
light it's fast and it's sharp and it
will kill
thank you very much
bladesmiths to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do i'll take
your yachtagon and deliver slashes and
thrust on this ballistics dummy dave
you're first are you ready yes sir let's
do this
i'm so nervous right now and i'm just
hoping my blade will perform well
this got bowels dropping out everywhere
let's talk about your weapon dave it
follows the feel of a yadagon that's
supposed to be light and deadly
the edge you have here is sharp where
it's curved into lacery
your yada gone will kill
thank you very much
all right gabe your turn you ready go
nuts man let's do this
dave's blade performed seemingly really
well guts falling out of the thing and
blood everywhere so a little
nerve-wracking knowing they'll have to
at least measure up to that
[Applause]
all right gabe
it is so light it really feels like it's
not there it's almost scary
when i thrust it penetrates easily and
slashes down
overall sir your blade
will kill right there
all right blazefist welcome to the kill
test
now we'll take your weapon there with
some thrust and slashes on this wild
boar carcass
zane you're up first you ready for this
ready as i'll ever be
this is the moment i have been waiting
for
i have been wanting to see my blade
attack a boar for the longest time and
it's happening now
this is gonna be really awesome
all right zayn let's talk about your
weapon here first up your tip is really
made to thrust it punctures really deep
when i'm thrusting with it but i can
move with this weapon you have a good
balance here the edge here is sharp as
you can see those are very very deep
sharp cuts
overall sir your weapon
will kill thank you doug
all right chris it's your turn you ready
yes sir
zayn's sponton had a
heck of an edge on that thing i'm just
hoping that mine does as well or better
i'm holding my breath
[Music]
all right chris so about your weapon
here what i love about this
is when you're thrusting i can feel the
weight in front and crunch ribs as it's
penetrating overall sir
your weapon will kill thank you sir
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
i'm gonna take your rapiers and deliver
some killing slashes and thrusts on this
big carcass
for these musketeer swords time to find
out if you're all for one champion or
one for all the runner-ups
jesse you're up first you ready for this
let's cut some bacon all right let's do
this
to be chopping into a full-size pig this
is crazy i'm worried because there's
bones inside that pig but
at this point it's in the judge's hands
and i can't wait to see what happens
[Music]
dude you gotta work out
all right jesse
this edge
is sharp
a rapier cut a big in half
that's very interesting
for every slash the edge lands exactly
where i want it to be okay overall sir
for this test
it will keep
all right ready teddy let's do it let's
do this
i'm nervous jesse goes first and doug
takes his sword and delivers some
massive slashes then he cuts the pig in
half so i hope mike can match that
oh
all right teddy
your edge when you're slashing with the
razor's edge that you have on your blade
it slices easily and deeply on this big
carcass your weapon sir
we'll kill awesome
[Music]
all right bladesmiths captain matt jack
churchill may have been mad enough to
take a back sword into modern combat
what i want to know is
are your swords mad enough if called
upon kill
to that end i will deliver some killing
blows to this ballistics dummy
did it hear up first you ready for this
i came here to watch you kill and chew
bubble gum and i'm out of bubble gum all
right
let's do this
there are a number of things that could
go wrong in this kind of test if my
blade gets twisted wrong maybe it breaks
it i i don't know i've never chopped
into a torso before
[Music]
[Music]
all right billy
first up i really like the way that the
damascus batter shows in your sword
now your handle
it's comfortable there are no hot spots
every cut you do with this blade is
sharp enough to cut deeply
overall
your weapon
will kill
thank you very much
all right robert your turn sir are you
ready i'm ready let's do this
[Music]
oh
i will not be denied
all right roberts talk about your back
sword here
the tip very pointy
thrust in easily cuts on the way out
your handle here it's loose it's really
wiggling in my hand
but overall sir your back sword
will kill
thank you
you